Noël Noël dans 27 jours maintenant
comment trouver des cadeaux sans trop se
ruiner ou pourquoi pas des cadeaux
éthiques on voit ça avec notre invité
bonsoir Joël Constanza bonsoir vous êtes
responsable de la communication à l'UFC
Que Choisir d'undreloire alors on va
parler de Noël évidemment mais d'abord
c'est le dernier jour du Black Friday
qu'on appelle
cybermander avec des ristournes sur les
équipements high-tech et multimédia
alors ça vaut vraiment le coup ou pas le
Black Friday alors c'est difficile à
dire on les études montrent que quand
même tout produit confondu
l'intérêt n'est pas aussi important que
que ça ce sont autour de 4-5%
tous les produits confondus bien sûr
alors je vais pas vous dire que ça ne
vaut pas le coup il y a peut-être des
très bonnes affaires à faire mais en
fait il faut toujours se méfier est-ce
que c'est vraiment est-ce que c'est
parce que c'est une promotion que il va
falloir que je l'achète parce que j'en
ai vraiment besoin déjà et multiplié
peut-être les recherches notamment chez
les concurrents
il faut faire attention d'abord repérer
est-ce que c'est vraiment une bonne
affaire est-ce que le prix barré
correspond bien à ce qui est marqué
normalement je vous rappelle que il y a
la directive
omnibus à ce qui est une directive
européenne qui est maintenant aussi
appliquée en France et qui dit que le
prix barré doit être le prix le plus bas
fait dans les 30 jours proposés dans les
30 jours avant la promotion voilà il
faut avoir une certaine mémoire des prix
des produits concombres très attention
parce que bien sûr il y a des enseignes
sur Internet qui ne jouent pas le jeu
alors pas de pénurie de jouer
cette année cette espèce de d'Arlésienne
mais leur prix augmente en ce moment
forcément c'est l'inflation 6 %
comment dégoter des jouets à moindre
prise qui a des périodes plus propres
prix propices pour les achats
normalement
si vous avez la chance d'avoir la lettre
du Père Noël très tôt octobre novembre
c'est bien de faire des achats à ce
moment-là d'abord parce que ça étale les
frais sur plusieurs semaines aujourd'hui
c'est trop tard ou disons qu'on va se
prévoir les augmentations il y a des
petites augmentations
jusqu'à Noël de quel ordre
quelques quelques euros mais ça augmente
quand même toujours parce que normal
c'est on est dans l'offre et la demande
donc pour l'an prochain un message au
Père Noël s'y prendre bientôt alors
depuis deux depuis des années on parle
de l'essor des jouets d'occasion
emportés par des convictions anti gaspi
de certains acheteurs aujourd'hui c'est
pour des raisons plus économiques encore
quelle place
justement pour ces jouets d'occasion
est-ce que il y a un vrai marché
aujourd'hui alors oui il y a un vrai
marché qui plus est jusqu'à présent
offrir des cadeaux de seconde main ça
faisait un petit peu radin
maintenant ça rentre un peu plus dans
les mœurs il y a 60% environ des 15-35
ans qui qui sont prêts à faire des ce
genre de choix alors pour des raisons
économiques mais aussi vous l'avez dit
pour des raisons écologiques de
consommation durable de recyclage etc
est-ce qu'on est obligé de dire que
c'est un jouet d'occasion non d'abord
parce que vous allez dans des bourses de
jouets les jouets qui sont proposés sont
d'excellentes factures enfin ils sont
ils sont pas quasi neufs pour certains
alors de même on entend de plus en plus
parler de Noël éthiques qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire exactement à Noël éthique et
comment s'y retrouver en fait alors que
moi je préfère
[Musique]
certains critères donc environnementaux
faut pas que ça pollue il faut pas non
plus qu'il y ait trop de transport bien
sûr parce que si vous faites venir vos
cadeaux de l'autre côté de la terre
plutôt du local il faut aussi que ça
respecte des critères éthiques sociaux
c'est-à-dire
conditions de travail on sait que
certains produits par exemple en Chine
peuvent être fabriqués par des
populations qui ne sont pas tout à fait
d'accord je ne vais pas revenir
là-dessus des conditions de travail
aussi c'est sécurité rémunération etc
donc on en trouve à la fois sur Internet
aussi au niveau local
la chance en plus maintenant d'avoir des
enseignes de jouets qui relocalisent en
France parce que bien sûr avec le coût
du trajet qui a explosé des transports
qui ont explosé ça revient moins cher
maintenant de faire des jouets en un mot
très très vite est-ce qu'il faut
craindre cette fois c'est pour le repas
du réveillon moins de volailles moins
d'un de moins de moins de 8
ça c'est sûr
de foie gravière la grippe aviaire aussi
le coût d'exploitation aussi de
production et puis les huîtres là c'est
pas la grippe c'est la chaleur de cet
été qui a fait que les huîtres ont moins
grossi donc il y aura 30 à 40% de moins
de production donc automatiquement un
petit peu plus cher changer le menu Noël
merci beaucoup
Joëlle ce soir